chances are you probably aren't overly
eager to lock lips with most of the
people at your job it's really no
different for actors but they have to do
it fairly often and sometimes the
results are as uncomfortable to watch as
they must have been to film well it's a
bit weird that a kiss between two
teenage characters would be widely
anticipated Harry Potter in the Deathly
Hallows Part 2 is a franchise concluding
exception Hermione Granger and Ron
Weasley's combative relationship begins
to soften ever so slightly once they
admit their romantic feelings for each
other after a particularly harrowing
series of events in which their survival
is far from assured Hermione and Ron
finally lock lips
but rather than taking the audience
deeper into this intense moment and the
terrifying events that preceded it their
kiss is awkward enough to have the
audience looking away talking to MTV
News Emma Watson confessed that she and
Rupert Grint were extremely
uncomfortable and nervous during filming
and Watson in particular since it was
her first proper onscreen kiss it's only
the only way it was honestly like
kissing my brother it was weird
silver linings playbook garnered a whole
host of award season attention this
quirky drama is about a mentally ill man
named Pat who is forced to move back in
with his parents after his marriage
falls apart while there he gets caught
up with Manic Pixie dream girl Tiffany
who manages to rope him into being her
dance partner for a ballroom competition
while their on-screen smooch did win an
MTV Movie Award for Best Kiss their
saliva swap whizzes awkward to film as
it was to watch on the Graham Norton
Show Cooper revealed that Lawrence
called him out on set for being a bad
kisser after the second take Lawrence
said you're a wet kisser you don't want
to hear that it was not a compliment
after proposing to his longtime
girlfriend fat Amy bumper is
unceremoniously and publicly dumped by
Amy who claims she is far from ready to
stop playing the field even though in
pitch perfect 2 and its predecessor
she's only been interested in him they
spent much of the movie apart until amy
has an epiphany at acapella boot camp
and decides she really does love him and
now wants to change her final answer to
a resounding yes to the tune of Pat
Benatar's we belong sung by rebel Wilson
and Adam Devine bumper and Amy reconnect
in one of the most Awkward kissing
scenes of the past decade although this
one's definitely awkward on purpose as
they weirdly lip-lock and roll around
the grass while also managing to keep
singing the awkwardness just heightens
the romantic comedy a factor Angelina
Jolie is no stranger to being called out
for awkward on-screen kisses which is
bizarre considering she's consistently
named one of the world's most beautiful
women first it was her uncomfortable and
passionless lip-lock with James McAvoy
in 2008's wanted which was as awkward to
film as it was to watch
[Music]
but this past decade she and co-star
Johnny Depp get the prize for lackluster
kissing scenes everyone expected to
smolder instead their make out sessions
are about as spicy as a boiled potato
and tap told the mayor that he was
uncomfortable filming the scenes and had
to use humor to get through them it just
goes to show that just because a movie
cast two gorgeous leads doesn't mean
there will be on-screen chemistry rush
an awkward situation as the dinosaurs
take over once again in Jurassic world a
lot of questionable things go down first
they've made a hybrid dinosaur from
recombinant DNA that is not only majorly
aggressive but it's chameleon traits
allow it to fully blend into any
surroundings second as Claire Owen and
her nephews are being hunted by
dinosaurs Claire and Owen share an
akward lip lock that is completely out
of place
[Music]
yes there are D times in life when a
well-timed kiss even amid inappropriate
circumstances can help to relieve
tension whether in real life or
on-screen but the jury is still out on
whether this applies to being under
attack from hordes of dinosaurs funnily
enough according to Jurassic world's
leading lady
the kiss was unscripted and spontaneous
which only makes it worse that it came
off so awkward Tate Taylor's revenge
horror movie MA features Octavia Spencer
as Sue Ann Ellington a veterinary
assistant in a small American town after
a group of high-school kids headed by
Andy Hawkins as Sue Ann to buy liquor
for them she realizes that these are the
children of her own high school bullies
and she begins concocting an elaborate
plan to get back at the people who most
badly hurt her as Sue Ann rampages our
way through her list of offenders she
ends up kissing young Andy who was
attempting to placate her more violent
impulses unlike many of the awkward
kisses of the last decade this scene is
orchestrated too creepy effect on
purpose highlighting sueanne's
post-traumatic psychosis as well as how
far the teens will go in order to
survive the Jennifer Lawrence and Chris
Pratt sci-fi drama passengers doesn't
only feature one of the most Awkward
kissing scenes of the past decade it's
also arguably one of the most
uncomfortable movies of the decade - boo
with an incredibly problematic plot
Pratt plays Jim a passenger on a space
colony ship who wakes up decades early
during the voyage he sees another
passenger Aurora whom he falls in love
with and decides to wake her up so he
won't be alone anymore he does this
despite the fact that doing so will doom
her to a lonely life and death on the
ship along with him yikes
it's a while before Aurora finds out her
awakening wasn't an accident like Jim's
at which point they've already begun a
relationship that includes physical
intimacy passengers was Jennifer
Lawrence's first sex scene as well as
her first time kissing a married co-star
she was so uncomfortable with the
scenario that she said she ended up
getting drunk to film their scenes which
only made the situation even more
awkward to film and to watch
[Music]
shailene woodley isn't only known for
her strong performances and films like
the divergent series as well as HBO's
big little lies she's also known to be
really into holistic therapies Chinese
medicine and clean eating you think her
healthy lifestyle would make her an
optimal kissing partner but her the
spectacular now co-star miles teller has
a different perspective talking to
variety teller recalls before our first
kissing scene she leaned took these
Chinese dirt supplements and shoved them
in her mouth it's like a dirt pouch and
it smells like crap
she always has a mason jar and 100% of
the time it smells like crap
high prom I had some this morning so you
might be like Shay stay away because you
have fire dragon breath luckily for
teller most of their kissing scenes were
in the middle of front and complicated
situations so we didn't necessarily need
to look like he was fully enjoying
things after several bombs master of the
twist ending M night Shyamalan returned
in 2016 with the multiple personality
horror movie split James McAvoy plays
Kevin Wendell Crum a man so traumatized
by the abuse he survived as a child he
has created an entire army of alternate
personalities that help them cope these
personalities have begun to merge into
the Horde and the beast a violent being
who defies the laws of nature the Horde
has kidnapped three high school girls
including Casey cook and is keeping them
prisoner for the beasts next meal one of
Kevin's alters is nine year-old Hedwig
who KC manages to bond with an almost
allows her to escape in the process how
do I Cass if he can kiss Casey who has
no choice but to comply
the result is one of the most awkward
kisses ever let alone the past decade
sorry
there was still so much that is unclear
about the sixth installment of the Alien
franchise set years after the future
events depicted in Prometheus alien
covenant finds the Android David after
he's fashioned himself a kingdom on the
home planet of humanity's creators
called the engineers David lures a
colony ship on their way to terraform a
new planet to his home on paradise where
he meets Walter a new Android model who
looks just like David David shows Walter
his creepy lair covered in sketches of
the xenomorph creature jars filled with
all kinds of weird stuff and a variety
of tools and instruments that david has
been creating or repurposing after
teaching Walter how to play the flute
David kisses Walter full on the mouth
why he does this is never explained
maybe an expression of pure narcissism
to kiss his identical twin but it is as
awkward as awkward gets made worse by
the fact that David tries to kill Walter
almost immediately after reese
witherspoon had a decidedly unpleasant
experience on the set of her carnival
period peace Water for Elephants with
co-star Robert Pattinson this romantic
drama stars Pattinson as Jacob a
veterinary student who drops out of
school to join the Benzini brothers
circus there Jacob meets Witherspoon's
Marlena and her abusive partner at the
big top ringmaster August he can't help
but fall in love with this beautiful but
damaged woman even though August temper
would put them all in danger if he ever
found out during one of their kissing
scenes the music swells and elaborate
and emotional waves but Pattinson later
totally ruined the moment in an
interview with MTV saying I was doing it
when I had a really bad cold my nose is
running all over the place and it was in
one of the additional photography scenes
and reset this wig on and literally I
was wiping my nose on her wig
Weatherspoon corroborated his story
saying he did have a very runny nose
yeah it wasn't appealing it wasn't
pleasant there's nothing like implied
incest to make any situation awkward and
we're the Millers drug dealer David
Clarke has to smuggle an RV full of
marijuana across the border and needs a
cover family to help he enlists dancer
Sarah rose to be his pretend wife and
run away Casey and his neighbor Kenny to
round out the fake family on the way
they link up with another family
and Kenny starts crushing on their
daughter Melissa Kenny wants to make a
move but doesn't know how to kiss so
Casey and Sarah Rose give him a detailed
tutorial of course Melissa walks in on
them horrified not realizing that these
folks aren't actually family at all
awkward since this reveal potentially
threatens their cover story more hijinks
ensue for the Millers according to actor
will Poulter the scene was as awkward to
film as it was to watch by the close of
avengers endgame the
long love affair between Captain America
aka Steve Rogers and Peggy Carter ends
up taking on new prominence as the
Avengers undo thanasis murderous snap it
was undeniable how much capital of Peggy
but Captain America Civil War features
an unintentionally awkward kiss between
cap and Peggy's great niece Sharon
Carter which takes place after they've
both attended Peggy's funeral Peggy
Carter actress Hayley Atwell herself
told Entertainment Weekly I wouldn't
want to date my great-aunts guy it just
feels like it crosses an incestuous
boundary and Peggy just died
that's even more disrespectful right
it's like don't touch that you can't top
that
not only does out will have an excellent
point Chris Evans and Emily VanCamp also
had questionable on-screen chemistry
that made a problematic kiss even more
awkward to watch check out one of our
newest videos right here Plus even more
looper videos about your favorite stuff
are coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and hit the belt so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]